live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships
you jump in we'll help you with your
life and your money dr john deloney
number one best-selling author and host
of the wildly popular ramsay network
production of the dr john deloney show
where he talks about all kinds of mental
wellness issues is my co-host today you
jump in we'll talk about your life in
your money triple eight eight two five
five
two two five charles is going to start
off this hour in portland oregon hey
charles how are you
i am dave i'm fine
um
the kind of question i have is a little
bit unusual in that
um last year my wife passed away i'm
sorry
and we were doing the baby steps but
that's kind of came to a stop
because without her income my only
income is social security and i'm trying
to figure out a way to
save
keep our house from going into
foreclosure
wow
i'm sorry
how long were you guys married um 18
years wow how old are you
um 64. how old was she
she passed away she was just turned 50.
whoa what
happened we were on our way home from a
dinner date and and i had met her after
work so we were in separate cars and i
exited the freeway where i live and she
was about two minutes behind me and
she got caught in a landslide whoa
no way
[Music]
wow
that's wild
man i'm sorry what a deal yeah
and i'm actually in
nashville right now um i just
took a picture with you yesterday oh
okay okay my daughter is the one going
to college here oh yeah i remember
talking to you yeah
yeah i'm sorry
talking about dad's checking into
beaumont yeah yeah um
[Music]
what do you owe on the house
um
right at 3 20. and what's the payment
um
just about 2 000
okay and what is your social security
um social security is about sixteen
hundred
okay
and um
how are you behind on the house
no we're up to date right now how
um
i've been using money from savings that
i got from the life insurance to keep
the house payment up got it how much was
the life insurance
well
it got split three ways because we had
me and the kids were all on it so the
life insurance company gave 35 to each
of the kids 30 to me of the percentage
so i ended up with about 170 000 but
when i
when she passed away to get all the
bills squared away and get us out of
debt and i had to pay off my car and my
daughter's car so i spent about a
hundred thousand getting us debt free
except for the house your daughter's
using her money to go to belmont
what's that your daughter's using her
money to go to belmont
well
yes and no um she got a bunch of
scholarships she had good grades she got
scholarships and stuff and so our total
bill for belmont was um just over 3 000.
oh nothing fantastic that's wonderful
what's the house what's it worth
um
according to online it would be worth
probably a little over five but the
online description of it is incorrect
they have it as a three bedroom and it's
really a four bedroom yeah so somewhere
but it's got you know you got you got a
400
anyway
yeah okay what what what is it about
staying in this home that's important to
you
well it's the only kids the kids in the
house the kids ever ever known but if i
were to sell it
housing in the portland area
i would not be able to get into another
house
[Music]
i'm making and what i'm asking you is
you're on social security now so that
tells me that you're untethered
what is it about portland
well what i hear i hear a guy who's got
a hole in the boat and he's determined
to stay in the bay that he's in
even if that means the whole thing sinks
yeah well i still have my son who's in
high school
great your son's going to want to stay
in a home
right so let me let me um
so
let's first establish this
okay
you i've been talking to you for a few
minutes you've been through a horrible
tragedy
and it breaks your heart and it clouds
and fogs your mind
if you're a normal human and you're a
normal human but you're a smart guy so
let's first establish a there's not
going to be
a foreclosure
that's not going to happen because you
would sell the house before you would
lose all of that equity unless you're a
fool
right
yeah okay so you're either going to get
your income going and pay the bill or
you're going to sell it
right but there's not going to be a
foreclosure you're going to sell it to
avoid
a foreclosure because you can't afford
it now i'm 62 you're 64. i work every
day why don't you
i've been on um i had two bouts of
cancer and i still have ongoing medical
issues with that
that's why i had to take an early
retirement from where i was working what
were you doing
airlines
what at the airport
uh what's that you're a pilot
no no uh aircraft mechanic okay all
right so i'm gonna start asking myself
if i'm you what i can do with my
medical limitations
to create five thousand dollars a month
and if i can't find that
then you need to sell your house
yeah i was looking into that but in the
area is if i sell the house the
apartment rents are higher than what my
mortgage payment is you're going to lose
the house
if you don't pay the payment or sell it
right
so there's no magic wand that gets you
out of this because rents are high in
portland oregon
so you are either going to create five
thousand dollars worth of income to be
able to pay the bill on a two thousand
dollar house payment and you can do you
know i'm not
panicking but you've got to start
thinking that i this is a math problem
and i've got to take action what happens
too many times when someone's gone
through a tragedy like you've gone
through
and then they get pinched in a situation
like this they tit a lot of people tend
to get paralysis and do nothing
and there's
and then they wait until it's too late
and they do lose the house so i'm
telling you
you need to actively proactively decide
in the middle of your grief which is
very hard to do
in the middle of your broken heart which
is very hard to do
what the next chapter of your career
looks like and you're there for your
housing
and so you you've got to go make some
money now you don't have to go to work
for somebody nine to five in corporate
america maybe you can't do that maybe
there's a side hustle maybe there's a
thing you do from home from the computer
i don't know what that thing is i will
send you
ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose to help you get through that but
it's a simple procedure charles as badly
as i hurt with you i'm also not going to
participate
in watching the boat sink
so either either fix the boat
or sell the boat don't sink the boat and
it's important to remember your wife is
no longer in that boat
she's gone
i think dave i think it's time to let
the house go man
you think it's better to let it go yeah
okay
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five number one
best-selling author ramsey personality
dr john deloney is my
co-host today
open phones here triple i'm hitting the
wrong buttons let's see if i can get the
right one there it is brian's with us in
dayton hey brian how are you
i'm doing great how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
i've got a real estate question for you
that i've never encountered before
my wife and i purchased the property in
january for 73 000 just as an investment
property
we paid cash for the property
and then in august on august 9th i got a
letter from the state saying that they
were they had put a 207 000 lien on the
property for medicaid recovery because
the previous owner had been on medicaid
and i didn't know if you'd ever
encountered anything like that or had
any advice on how to deal with that
did you buy title insurance
we do have title insurance and i did
file a claim last week they've they
assigned a lawyer to it but they haven't
really gotten back to him i don't know
was the was the lien filed by the state
prior to the closing of the property
no the lien was filed on march 10th so
two months after we purchased it
well
and again you know you need you you got
in touch with the title company but i
don't think the state has the power to
retroactively
lean something i mean why can they not
put a lien on your property 15 years
later
it's here's the thing
who owned the house at the time the lien
was placed the guy that they're placing
the lien on
didn't own the house anymore so the only
thing the state can do is try to find
yours the seventy thousand dollars he
got from the sale of the property the
state has no right to place a lien on
your property
well that's exactly what i thought but
then i called the attorney who sent a
letter and he said the state has a year
to file the lien and i said well you
know the estate doesn't even own the
property anymore so how can they file a
ring on me so i guess that's kind of
where we're at yeah they can't go back
and get stuff that the guy used to have
yeah
um right
i've never heard of this emailed the
attorney general's office they said
they'd look into it i even emailed my
state representative
yeah i contacted you i don't think
number one if there is a legitimate lien
that can be done i and i don't think it
is okay i bought 2 000 pieces of real
estate i've bought stuff and then the
title turned up bad i bought a house one
time and
the title company neglected to figure
out that there was a brother with the
two sisters that were selling it and it
was an estate and the brother didn't
sign off because they didn't bother to
figure that out and so uh the title
company ended up writing the brother a
check in order for him to sign a release
because old dave already owned the
property and so i'm a huge believer in
title insurance for that reason i'm
really thankful you've got it but i
think the answer is your title insurance
company is going to solve this
if the lien is legitimate i don't think
it is
because of because it comes after the
deed is filed
okay you can't just file crap after the
deed is filed you can only file it prior
to if they filed it prior to
that's fine but um
you know no i think the lawyer's smoking
crack but i may be wrong i mean it just
it would out of out of all the real
estate deals i've done and i've been
doing real estate bills deals for 40
years i've never heard of a deal like
this that would stay put so prior to
yeah and the title company missed it
well title company's getting ready to
write a check
okay and uh but uh this is not prior to
i don't think this lawyer's got a case i
think the state's screwed up but but if
he does the title company is your best
bet to handle it um really not the
attorney general and really not and the
attorney general works for the state
it works for the same people they're the
ones that follow the lien i know it's
the same being unethical yeah it's the
same people yeah
so um all right
i'm gonna guess and say this is not as
much unethical as it is just incompetent
yeah this is an accident but um
and then the lawyer just was he thought
he'd see if he could push you around a
little bit see if he could get the money
but i nah
i don't think so
that's like
coming out three cars later like hey
this guy who bought this cadillac seven
years ago he owes us some money so you
need to give us that car
let's can't do that well you can do that
in the case of theft if you stole it
that's right if it was stolen and fenced
or like buying stuff at a pawn shop
because somebody can come back if you
bought it from a fence if you bought
stolen items you'll lose that item
that's true but in real estate the
ownership is established and the title
the cleanliness of the title is
established at one place in one place
only and that is in the register of
deeds at the courthouse that's true in
every state in the united states and so
in real estate law they taught us as we
were as i got a degree in real estate
it's called a race to the courthouse
whoever files
first
does when so so let's say you and i both
have a deed to a piece of property in
our hand
the one that files it first is the owner
i'm letting that air out of your tires
there it is so there's no such thing as
that happening but i mean the concept
being you know if you have a lien
and you don't get it filed before the
property is sold so you've got to try to
take action against the former owner and
get money out of his bank account that
he got from the sale which is the
state's position here and the lien was
technically your collateral and you
missed it right yeah yeah you know and
so uh now in the event of a foreclosure
they can go back on the rights of
redemption there is that but not after a
straight arm's length transaction sale
you just can't really nearly walk along
and just start plopping stuff down on
other people's property
it's just that just doesn't make sense
so i may be getting ready to learn
something i may get a letter from the
state of uh wherever he was telling me
i'm wrong ohio but i don't think i will
um we'll see uh and and you know if you
have a situation like this he did the
exact right thing he went to the title
company
one more time never buy a house or any
piece of property ever without title
insurance
for 99 of you that are not professional
contractors don't buy a house without a
home inspection
if you are buying a piece of property
other than a standard
cookie cutter subdivision lot
if it is a quote piece of ground
always get a survey
because neighbors have funny memories
about surveys and about
right-of-ways and about all these other
things and so you need to actually know
what it is you're getting and sometimes
a survey is costly on a piece of
ground
a piece of rural property because you
know it's from the old oak tree to the
pile of rocks in the corner literally my
neighbor told me your your place starts
over at that rock under the tree that's
a that's a that's a verbatim quote
that's right yeah that's um he's
accurate but that was the quote i've
sold enough farm property in tennessee
that and tennessee's very irregular
property lines not like the midwest
where you've got squares and townships
and everything's in a perfect little
square and you can figure it out but
not in tennessee
it may follow the creek and it might not
follow the creek so you just don't know
you really need to get a survey and so
um
or the crick as the case may be but um
yeah so yeah
it's so real estate is it's a fun
business but always
take the time to get your documentation
i sure hope the guy hadn't lost 70 grand
but i don't think he has hope he doesn't
lose a penny in legal fees here
um wow that's pretty ballsy right there
but we'll see
i've got bigger concerns if
my the state government can just write
me a letter that says hey the guy who
before you had some problems we're going
to take that you yeah we or your
yourself
i mean you would think the irs would
pull something like that yeah they don't
place a lien after the fact now if they
place a lien prior to
they just put nails in the coffin of the
guy he's stuck right
but uh man cause the irs dealing with
kgb is a trip
but uh uh
man
but yeah
that's an interesting story right there
very interesting hey every time you hear
someone do their debt-free scream it's
because at some point they said i've had
enough i'm not living like this i've had
it and when you get mad like that
and you do what they did your life will
change
right now inflation stupid credit card
bills waiting on
washington to fix your life by forgiving
your student loans not going to happen
he's going to announce this week that
student loans are going to be forgiven
you need to read the fine print he
doesn't have the power to he's not
really going to do it he's going to do
something that sounds like he did it so
that he can get some help into the
midterms for his buddies that's all
that's coming you have to take the
course that gives the step-by-step plan
that helps you get out of debt and be
able to build wealth it's called
financial peace university nearly 10
million people have beat debt using this
they've learned how to budget have
learned how to become outrageously
generous and become wealthy guys stop
letting your debt and money stress
control your life say enough
go to ramseysolutions.com
enough
and we'll get you into financial peace
university help get this stuff going
ramsay solutions.com
enough
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage patrick
and beth are with us hey guys how are
you hey dave welcome where do you live
uh midland michigan oh yeah fun welcome
to nashville and here to do a debt-free
scream how much did you pay off
245 thousand dollars
yay how long did this take two years
good for you boom knocking it out
and your range of income during that
time 190 000 to 250.
nice jump in two years what do you guys
do for a living uh we are in medical
sales both of you both of us okay
so uh what do you attribute the sixty
thousand dollar increase in pay y'all
just sold a whole bunch of more medical
so he sells medical plexi glasses
exactly so the bulk of it was really
that uh about change jobs oh she went to
a different position ah that's much more
lucrative then that's exactly right yeah
well to go good for you guys fun fun fun
excellent proud of you oh so okay so
what kind of debt is this 245 000 this
was our house dave oh yeah
weirdos yes couple of weirdos with us i
love it all right weirdos how old are
you i'm 37
and i will be 40 next month that was our
main goal to do it before i turn 40. and
you did yes okay so what's this house
worth
uh so we actually just talked to one of
your elps and it's between 550 and 600.
okay and how much in your retirement
accounts uh between 600 and 650. so you
are baby steps millionaires we are there
easy and then some before you're 40.
i love you guys you're amazing
okay how much of this is due to you
stealing the money
none okay because most everybody knows
the rich people are crooks right yeah
and you don't look like crooks to me so
uh wow you guys congratulations thank
you bam thank you that
i'm kind of speechless because you're
not even 40 yet
and you're millionaires and i just keep
looking at these three little kids and
when you said we're millionaires they
smiled which means y'all had this
conversation yes which is
that i mean i'm just watching a legacy
change right in front of me it's
beautiful
what was the hardest part about this
journey
uh you know for me it was really
um just trying to stay motivated um
through that two years and so being the
mortgage it was you know we'd go to the
bank once a month and make a big payment
and i'm kind of a rip the band-aid off
kind of guy
so i wanted to make that next payment
and that next payment so just waiting
that 30 days to make that next payment
was really really tough for me
so actually what i did was started
making payments every two two weeks that
way i could kind of get that
you know that high of of making that
payment and then just waiting another
two weeks rather than having to wait an
entire month scott got he got a dopamine
hit making payments
[Music]
i hated that bank so much
that's a good bank to hate right there
well done what was your favorite uh in
retrospect now
what was your favorite disagreement over
the last few years because i mean
250 thousand dollars y'all paid off
y'all could have done a lot of fun stuff
with that money
we could have but i mean it was
definitely worth it um you know i've got
i've got a great wife
and uh
probably one of the biggest
disagreements is um
i guess she wanted to get her hair done
yeah and i'm such a cheap hell that it
was always you don't have anything i
don't have any
i don't have any i think yeah he's right
i would say that yeah um it was you know
those little things we
were huge in budgeting we weren't
previously um where it was we did
we kept track of where our money went at
the end of the month but eventually we
told our money where to go and that was
huge
um how did you get connected up with the
ramsey way this whole process with that
yeah so actually um i was introduced to
you about 13 14 years ago when i started
dating this girl that was reading the
total money makeover
and she was working on getting some
credit card debt out of the way and i
just at that point in my life i wasn't
ready to follow someone else's plans
because i thought i was just too smart
and
so fast forward i convinced that girl to
marry me and then we lived the next nine
years of marriage just being normal
and then one day i was driving down the
road and one of my co-workers
uh she said you know maybe you should
find a podcast to listen to because i
was sick of listening to the same songs
over and over and so at that point in
time i was looking at how do i start a
zero down
uh real estate portfolio and so i typed
into the podcast financial podcast and
up came the dave ramsey show so i
thought hey i remember this guy
so i downloaded the the podcast and the
first
uh show that i listened to was a dave
frant
and you were talking about be a victim
in your story and that really hit home
with me and then you started talking
about leaving a legacy and changing your
family tree and that's really where
something just snapped inside of me
and so i actually went home and i had
about twenty thousand dollars in student
loan debt at that time we had a big
big savings account because we thought
that's what safety was and so i told
beth we're gonna pay off this student
loan debt
and we sat down that night at the
computer paid it off she's like who are
you and what are you doing
she was just waiting for me yeah i've
heard of women playing a long game that
was well played
that's a long time she knew it was in
there yeah wow yeah i've had your book
since 2009 took us a while but we got
there and so then once we paid the
student loan debt off it was like that
was too easy so what was next was the
mortgage and i knew that in order to
really
make that change behaviorally i had to
have some kind of sacrifice so that's
where i got the idea of you know what
let's just tackle this mortgage and it
started off as a five-year plan and then
quickly became you know a two-year
journey so you got addicted to the
making payments that's exactly right
yeah that progress okay it'll hook you
yeah and especially our kids so our kids
were huge motivation for us
um i can remember
so my my daughter she would help color
in the bricks on the charts that we were
using
and early on in the process i just made
like a you know four or five thousand
dollar payment at the bank so i was i
was walking pretty high
and i came home and madison she colored
in a couple of bricks and then she
looked at me and she said dad we've got
to do more
[Laughter]
love it madison jack them up
i love it all right how does it feel to
be completely
free
uh
i don't think it's fully set in uh but
it's it's it's incredible i mean it's
just just waking up every morning
knowing that
you know no matter what happens a
pandemic whatever nobody's taking our
house amen
amen congratulations guys changes
everything so proud of y'all thank you
are amazing all right bring the kiddos
up and let's introduce them we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
uh how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth you can too these
guys did it they're 40 years old we're
gonna give you another copy of it or
give you a copy of it you should be in
there and a financial peace university
membership for a year uh you're welcome
to give any of this away if you want and
uh get somebody else's journey started
and also a total money makeover book
totally for you to give away because
you've already got one so
thank you
all right what are the kids names and
ages so this is madison she's nine
this is which one are you this is henry
he's six and this is hugh and he is six
as well oh a couple twins
that's why we gotta look and see who
they are and madison is the lady with
the bricks
she's like dad we gotta do more way to
go madison way to go madison you're
amazing
very cool hey you guys changed your
family tree i'm so proud of you it's a
complete we're looking at the picture of
a legacy right in front of us not even
40 years old
so very powerful well well done patrick
and beth madison henry and hugh 245 000
paid off housing everything in the
process becoming baby steps millionaires
they did it in two years making 190 to
250. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream ready guys
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh fabulous
oh man
dave how do
we have to have this talk real quick
what are we supposed to say about
getting our wives getting their hair
their hair done
nothing nothing
[Laughter]
but the uh
but here's the thing
the the
the spouse that is on board
is going to
always control and be reasonable about
any expenses
um and so if i've got an expense it
wouldn't be hair with me obviously it'd
be something else that's associated then
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna limit that
because
we have a goal
so i'm going to limit if i'm the lady
the hair the nails and stuff to a
reasonable
level uh maybe scale back from normal to
be able to hit the bigger goal it's part
of the spirit of the process of doing
this together but yeah i don't get to go
in and say
you don't know i don't have that option
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsay to get
the best possible deal
today's question comes from brian in
texas brian asks i'm 27 years old with a
bachelor's degree in accounting and 40
000 in debt 28k in student loans and 13
000 in credit cards
have a full-time job making 41 grand a
year and live at home
they i'm assuming it's his parents want
me to stay with them as long as possible
because they are as long as possible
because they are enablers
i want to move out and i ask them to set
a deadline for when i have to move
okay they are giving me until february
of 2023. this is so backwards i don't
have any money saved because i've been
throwing it all the debt is it wise to
stay with my parents till i'm debt free
or save up and move out while continuing
to pay off debt
yeah there's a lot of
[Music]
things happening backwards here
yeah i would simply usually parents
throw the kids out the kids don't ask
the parents to throw them out that's a
little backward yeah well it's like mom
and dad are saying we want you to stay
with us forever and then he says no give
me a date when i have to be gone and
they're like okay a year
and he's like yeah
i get it dude brian listen if you were
here with us we'd all be laughing and
you know that we'd be laughing here's
the thing um save up some money and get
an apartment
or yeah
i mean yeah
give out and
i don't know why you only make 41 000 a
year with a degree in accounting
yes
your job sucks
you need to go get king coleman's book
and look for a better job
um
also you know that's
horrid um
no you do not need to stay there until
you're debt-free that is not a guideline
yes it would be mathematically more
efficient
i will tell you from personal experience
brian that um
i observed
each of my children after college
either
setting up house on their own so to
speak
or one of them actually moved and lived
with us for about three months and then
with the game plan to move out very
quickly
but in every case when they moved out
and had to buy their own milk
had to pay their own light bill or the
electricity got cut off
had to buy groceries or there was
nothing in the refrigerator had to do
laundry or there was no clean underwear
in every case when they did had to do
those basic
menial
adult tasks
i
visibly watched them change
in that first year they were out and
they were already mature hard-working
good
people
but i watched their
emotional development accelerate
when they left the nest
and some more obvious than others in
different situations
but it was it was
palatable
that uh no more checks coming from me
and no more laundry done by your mom
and when they had to pick up that and
run with it it changed everything so
yeah i always recommend as quickly as a
young person
can reasonably get out on their own even
though it does not appear to be
mathematically the correct thing to do
it generally ends up being
mathematically the correct thing to do
because it accelerates you
and you are what creates your income so
you probably even though you might not
associate it with the activity of having
moved out
it
changes how you walk it changes your
swagger
your body language and so you go get
money more often right and uh because
you turn out turn out to need money out
here in the world and so
it's just good and it's good for you i
would tell you i would highly recommend
you do that not in a panic not in a
freak out i mean if you want it but i
wouldn't wait until february and i
certainly wouldn't wait till you're out
of debt i'm proud of him for recognizing
wait a minute i'm being enabled
my immaturity is i i'm you know it took
him till he's 27 for goodness sakes but
hey you figured it out move out and
let's get this thing going
some people are 35 45 55 and they
haven't figured out yet that well
they're like characters in a movie
though i mean that's just ridiculous
yeah or callers on my show yeah
well yeah i mean it's you listen uh uh
uh an eagle that does not leave the nest
eventually is called a turkey right so
you you need to um or the way i describe
it is if you are constantly going into
the weight room and helping your kids
lift the weight
they are never going to develop their
own muscles and eventually your your
helping them out
causes them it is the extension of the
helicopter mom that's a helicopter
parent uh syndrome to just keep them in
the basement forever
like
oh well okay yeah uh ashley's in denver
hey ashley what's up
hi thank you for taking my comment sure
how can i help
sorry i apologize i'm a little nervous
um we've never lost a patient
what's up
uh i had a question or a couple
questions in regards to my student loans
um i recently received notification that
they are
they have been approved to be forgiven
through a class action lawsuit
um and through the research that i've
done i can't quite determine if this is
taxable income or non-taxable income
they're forgiven because the uh it
sounds like it was a private
uh school and it went broke
yes yes it's um the lawsuit currently
going on through the department of
education yeah yeah yeah and uh there's
been a couple of big ones come down
lately and you're probably in that yeah
so that is one of the instances that
student loan forgiveness is real and
does happen so i'm guessing that
probably a very very likely case that
your student loans will be forgiven now
normally debt that is forgiven
is taxable income for instance if you
owe
a mastercard four thousand dollars and
you don't pay them and they send you a
letter saying uh you know
you own five thousand dollars they send
you a letter saying for 50 bucks we'll
forgive this you send them 50 bucks then
you get a tax bill for the difference
you get a 1099 receipt for the
difference on taxable income i do not
know on student loan forgiveness due to
fraud by the
uh which is what this case is
by the institution
if that is a taxable event or not that
may be nuanced under the law and it may
be a type of
debt of forgiveness that is not
uh taxable but otherwise debt
forgiveness is taxable
by and large i mean um
so what i would do if i were in your
shoes because i don't know the answer to
your question i'm sorry
is i would go to ramseysolutions.com
click on elp for taxes get a tax
professional that we recommend and they
can look up the regulation on this
particular thing this nuanced part of
the law and see if there's any
uh anything that goes with that it
wouldn't surprise me if it's not taxable
it really shouldn't be
it makes sense it's logical that other
types of debt forgiveness are taxable
because that's money that you
owe in this case they're saying you
really don't owe it because you weren't
really given anything
by this horrible incompetent institution
that went broke tell me about this i
didn't know this so
if i owed fifty thousand dollars
somebody pays off that debt
the government registers that gap as
income
yes okay yeah even if it goes down
that right but even if it goes directly
to the lender not through me
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
who no i mean if they forgive the debt
like it usually comes up if you're
negotiating a balance on an old bad debt
uh okay you know like you owe them ten
thousand dollars from five years ago on
a mastercard and you call up citibank
and you argue with them and they go well
you know we'll take two thousand dollars
of settlement
but i pay taxes on that eight yep wow i
didn't know that okay they're gonna send
a 10.99 out on that they're supposed to
because they're writing it off because
they it's a business loss for them and
it's a gain for you right because money
you legitimately owed
but because you weren't because it was
bad debt they decided to take less for
it
so you did gain from that but the theory
in the student loan forgiveness is that
these uh jack leg
weird private school things you know
would go
semi scam type thing they were predatory
yeah they're predatory they would get
people into debt and then the education
or the certifications that they gave
them weren't worth anything right
and would go broke and so
really you haven't gained it's about
making you whole yeah they're just
making you whole here so it's a
different
theory anyway but whether or not they're
going to tax that i don't know have to
check your tax personally
not very good at some of those things
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth and do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships dr john deloney ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the
wildly popular dr john deloney podcast
on ramsey networks is my co-host today
thank you for joining us america mike is
in orange county california hey mike how
are you
hi dave hi dr d i hope you guys are
sitting down because this is probably
going to make your head hurt um bring it
challenge acceptance let's start the
hour out with that hold our beers mike
let's do this a brief background i'm a
twin i was adopted at birth to a
wonderful family
about 20 years ago i researched my birth
family and made connections my
twin had no interest at all in
connecting with the family i've
developed a relationship with
the existing family which was my birth
mother
a half brother and a birth uncle
my birth mother and uncle have
been vacant from the family since i
joined the family my uncle
passed away a week ago
and i just learned that i was the
executor of his my wife and i are the
executor of his trust
and his he left us his condo
which is old skin needs some work um but
we're navigating one financially do we
keep the condo rent it
and or do we sell it how much work do we
put into it and secondly
i'm already getting calls from my birth
mother and uh half brother
claiming that they're entitled to the
property and
my half brother already said that i need
to fire sell it and send him a hundred
thousand dollars immediately
my uncle's wishes he clearly
communicated to me and his character
that he didn't want them having anything
to the point where i asked him about a
antique picture and he said if arlene
takes it uh she would only sell the
frame
um so she he feel feels strongly that
they had both stolen from him over the
years so i'm trying to navigate the uh
relationship that's his sister and his
nephew
correct okay and uh he didn't have a
sibling or children
he he was never married
no children okay and did he have a
written will
he's got a written will and a trust
leaving me as the executor of the trust
and leaving
my wife and i
everything except for his car and a
small savings account that he wants to
go to his um
caretaker yeah
okay
well i'm so sorry what a pinch to put
you in after all the weirdness of this
whole thing
so how is your relationship before all
this happened with your half brother and
your birth mom
uh
intermittent
she had violated a number of um
boundaries that we had set
just to give you a feel for it so she
has she has her own issues
she's got plenty of issues
um how did
i met her how ironic that your
relationship ends up being with your
uncle
that you also didn't know
that's
ironic but he was i mean he was lonely
uh he was he was closer than her he's
just
a die-hard sweet man he worked for a
toyota dealership for 46 years working
on their lot he's just just a blue
collar sweet guy
that i developed a relationship with so
mike here's a here's a common
situation here
is you
really hanging on to
this is hard what i'm about to say okay
hanging on to a fantasy
a myth
that somehow this
relationship with your birth mother is
going to be restored to what it should
have been
or what it could have been
same with your no same with your hat
not at all okay okay i am more concerned
about
than the conversation
the conversation ends there
okay any more noise that you allow into
your head is a choice you're making
okay okay
do you have no moral
or legal obligation to give either one
of them adam in fact i would suggest
based on what your uncle looked you in
the eye and told you
you you'd be violating
his wishes by so here's what i remember
here's my answer if i'm you to your half
brother to your mom and just go
this is really awkward for all of us i
love you guys and i'm really sorry we're
in this situation
here's my legal
obligation
i am the executor of the estate which
means i am legally bound
to execute
to follow through on
the written wishes
of your uncle your brother
i don't have a choice i have to do what
that says
or i am liable
for legal action
that's why they call it an executor
because a a mic an executor executes
the terms of the will
that's all they do they don't get to
make up
new wills they don't get to change the
deal
they just have to do what the deal says
that's the law mike
you don't have a choice
now once you have executed your uncle's
wishes
which happens to be in this case that
you become the owner of all of these
things
if you choose to give away your stuff
then
that's you
choosing to give away your stuff but if
you give away your stuff to someone who
is demanding it in order to give them
in order to create a relationship hint
hint there was never a relationship to
start with relationships that are based
on a financial transaction are called
prostitution
and so if the only way your brother half
brother's ever going to speak to you
again is if you give him your money he's
opting out he's all he's checked out
same thing with uh
arlene or whatever her name was but yeah
i i i but that doesn't make this easier
that is just the correct thing to do
but people that function like your
birth mom and your half brother
are they are guilt their their travel
agents for guilt trips
they feel entitled to other people's
stuff
so if i choose to leave all of my money
to one kid
and the other two kids get
nothing it was my money
they are not entitled
not even legally entitled if i have a
will that says they don't get it
you know if i look at one of my two kids
my one of my three kids go heroin addict
i am not funding your
addiction your death
uh you get zippo because you have zippo
character and i put that in the will
he's got no moral rights no spiritual
rights no legal rights
and by the way that would have been an
act of love
because your uncle looked at her and
said money is not a blessing to
this lady when she gets it she
misbehaves with it it's a curse so i'm
not going to bother her with the curse
sorry mike it's hard to go through what
you're going through i hate it for you
but that you know i would just bad guy
off your uncle and go gosh i'm i'm kind
of handcuffed here i'm just the executor
i don't have any legal choices i have to
do
what the will says
and i don't sorry if you get you don't
even be mad go go out the graveyard and
yell at the tombstone
because i'm not here i can't do anything
about this
but it's not gonna end well no these two
goobs are going to be goobs cause
they're goops
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
how many times do you
kick the can down the road you say one
day i'll be able to buy a house one day
i'll be happy with my career one day i
won't have to battle with anxiety one
day i'll get my student loan paid off
one day i'll
you listen you got to stop it
whatever your one day is you need to
start
so that one day becomes now let's get
after it this is why we created smart
conference we have some of the top
thought leaders and speakers
in the world
speaking at smart conference
their best-selling number one
best-selling authors world-class
communicators in all kinds of different
areas
rachel cruz will be there speaking on
money dr john deloney sitting to my
right will be there speaking on mental
wellness ken coleman on career
our hottest new ramsey personalities in
the money space george campbell
christina ellis will be there
in full force i'll be speaking it's
october 22nd in dallas craig and amy
groschel pastors from life church will
be there speaking on marriage and man
they're great
so a little bit of everything leadership
marriage
money
mental wellness everything it's an all
day long event the vip and platinum is
all sold out there is a few general
admission passes left for only 39
and we want you to come
we want you to be
part of the program we want you to be
there with us all day on october the
22nd in dallas on a saturday
yeah if you would pay more than 39 here
any one of these people speak and you
got the whole line up all day it's the
smart conference you will leave smarter
ramsey solutions.com events get your
event passes ramsey solutions.com
events also check out the building
wealth series we're going to be in about
five or six different cities this fall
and there's a few of those tickets left
as well maybe we'll be in your city
peter is with us in chicago hi peter how
are you
hi doing good how about yourself better
than i deserve what's up
so a little bit of background um for the
last three years since the pandemic i
have been paying for my parents
mortgage and home equity
my
question is
unfortunately i think i missed the
opportunity for low rates but my
question is
i still have three options i can either
continue paying the um principal and
interest which i'm currently doing
they're covering the property taxes
that's option number one continue what
i'm currently doing paint three thousand
dollars a month with that um why are you
paying your parents mortgage
well
because they currently can't afford it
they want to stay in their house i'm an
only child and i would do and will do
anything i can to
pay them back for being fantastic
parents and giving me an amazing job to
help them avoid reality why can't they
pay their mortgage
uh
at the start of the pandemic my
dad had to
retire um
and um my
um
team continuing industry uh that had
some ageism uh and he just aged um he
was kind of forced to age out a little
bit how old is he uh he is 66.
so what did he do for a living
uh he is a substitute teacher
right now before he was um in another
industry he was making both of my
parents are in their 70s
as as professors
as
as teachers
and that's definitely an option because
you could take
can you afford 3 000 i mean this is
different do you make 25 grand a month
and this is no big deal
um
i should probably know a month off top
my head but for a year it's a 110.
it's like how old are you
29.
and you're single i'll take it
yeah
okay
all right
uh you live with them
i did move back to the during the
pandemic which is why i was happy to
help them out um to take a step back
dave this was
not um supposed to be a long-term
solution it was supposed to be temporary
yeah
intention of getting a gaming job he was
really good in his industry he had
and they have no money
um
their combined prime making around
45 a year yeah and what's the house
worth
it's uh seven sometimes yeah and what do
they owe on it
uh they owe
283.
you know they need to sell it and buy a
house for five hundred thousand it's
paid for
yeah uh
that's a that's a non-starter um no
the non-starter is this dysfunctional
crap that you're weaving that is your
life that's the non-starter
the non-starter is that the 29 year old
is taking care of these fully capable
adults who need to get off their butts
and take care of themselves
it is not an act of love
there is so much weirdness going on
behind the scenes in this conversation i
can't breathe especially some sort of
return on investment as though
they were great parents and so they're
entitled to x percent of your
of your income because they don't want
to work yeah or they didn't save up or
they made some life choices i'm all
about helping your parents out man but
let's pretend that you had a job that
was making twenty thousand dollars a
year and you were in an apartment
uh and they were in this pickle you know
what they would do
they would sell their house and buy a
500 000 house and get a job to be able
to live there
that's what they would do so it's not a
non-starter
uh you are trying to make their fantasy
world exist and it's not sustainable and
you are participating in the fantasy as
though the fantasy that you can prop
them up and keep this thing going
forever
this is has such a short runway and it's
gonna then it's gonna hit the wall and
it's gonna disintegrate like nascar and
the engine is gonna fly up in the stands
i mean this is this is you got about two
to three years on this before the all
the emotions in this mess melt down and
the and the finances unravel
so this is not a refinance question this
is a uh peter you've made some you guys
have made a mistake of trying to you
were nice to come in and and
with an umbrella when it was raining
but an umbrella is not a structure
that's sustainable
in a in a monsoon and you're that so
these folks need to make some decisions
about their income and their housing
like grown-ups and then you need to go
on and love them
be kind to them and you can assist them
occasionally but this idea that you took
them to raise is just dysfunctional dude
that's the non-starter yeah
it's it's just all in your story and
it's weird
and i'm not picking on you i'm not
shaming you i i just want you to hear it
loud and clear because you aren't you're
nowhere near hearing it that's why i'm
smacking you so hard because i really
want to shake you a little bit and give
get your attention because um
this is not good
mental health it's not good relational
health but more importantly you're
you're intentionally sacrificing your
future to not to keep somebody alive but
to prop up a fantasy there's two and
there's a difference there right
um
they're sitting on half a million
dollars
yeah anyway we could talk all day yeah
let's call it that that's the thing
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so here's the
thing
john let's talk about this minute
because it comes up with boundaries
issues and this is a kind of a
boundaries question in a sense
all the time
um
this we call we call uh the 30s and 40s
he's a little young for it but we call
them the sandwich generation
because they've got their kids to raise
them put through college and many times
their parents
have got issues and is there sandwich
between both of the financial needs
pulling at them
so you have to have
real clear boundaries and love and many
of uh many of my brothers and sisters in
christ
um
twist
and make toxic
the scripture that says to honor your
father and mother
and that means that we have to do
whatever no it doesn't
if your mom is doing cocaine you are not
honoring her by giving her money right
it's not honor
that's participation in dysfunction
that is not honoring that is not an act
of love
that is not an act of honor
that is a dysfunction
and that you can't you can't throw a
bible scripture over it and make it okay
he didn't do that no but i hear this all
the time that's right and you honor
someone by loving them well
and that's helping them get into a
sustainable healing situation and
telling the truth that's the truth and
not sacrificing your 60s 70s and 80s
because of their dysfunction back when
you were 20 and 30 absolutely
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're so glad you're here in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the dead
freeze stage
kirby and amber are with us where do you
guys live omaha nebraska all right cool
now we met yesterday we did at the
commercial break i came out you said
tomorrow we're doing the debt free
screen so now you're back with the uh
living like no one else t-shirts ready
to rock that's a brave couple that wears
matching t-shirts in public yeah that's
uh that's like you're going steady or
something gross
pretty cool guys how much debt did you
pay off
a hundred and twenty four thousand
ninety dollars i love it how long did
this take 31 months wow and your range
of income during that time 95 to 124
000. cool what do y'all do for a living
um
i'm a nurse
and in short i fertilize and spray weeds
okay
that'll work chemical apple don't work
he's trying to think about how he was
going to describe okay very cool good
for you guys all right what kind of debt
was 120 for everything literally um it
was student loans personal loans family
loans credit cards car loans my god
y'all were normal yes normal sucks yes
it does no fun at all everything but the
mortgage yeah we're still working on
that way to go guys man i'm so proud of
you how long you been married
eight years
okay so
two and a half years ago so five years
into marriage
something happens and you go all right
this has got to change tell me the story
how did you get to connect with this
ramsey way um so in 2017 we bought our
first home
and our down payment was a family loan
of course yes it was
so then um in 2018 july 5th 2018 we had
our major like a
our main pipe and our house flood our
house and we have three stories because
it's a chinese got the whole house oh
yeah i mean it came from everywhere god
so we are the poster children to
not buy a house until you have an
emergency yes
um it was a seventy thousand dollar
claim and we had to pay 30 of that out
of our pocket yep why
um because when they started taking out
the walls there was mold from
the previous last time it did oh yeah
yeah so obviously it flooded at some
point before
and then other stuff happened in between
and so um we had to take out a twenty
thousand dollar personal loan and put
ten thousand dollars on a credit card
um in addition to everything else that
we had so
oh and the smoke clears you have an oh
crap moment oh yeah
which which parent loaned you the down
payment um it was a grandma oh who
loaned you the other one
uh well that was a personal in credit
cards yes banking it was a
yeah so it was very very stressful um
during that time i was actually getting
my master's degree i was working
full-time and there was just some other
stuff going on that it was the most
stressful time in our lives
and
i went to work one day and i was telling
one of my co-workers about what we were
having to do and she's like have you
ever heard of dave ramsey
and so i was like no
um so she's like well just listen to
them does he fix flooded housing
can he drywall yeah i can't yeah
so
um i ended up listening to the podcasts
and i was listening to him for about a
month
and we ended up going on vacation
um in november of
2019 which is what we always do when
we're broke yeah well we were
technically still following your plan at
that time but we decided to
um take some time off but
um so on our way to kansas city i was
like hey let's listen to this podcast i
heard about
um and he got hooked after that i wasn't
fully on board at the beginning so oh
okay she stuck me in the car with you
and her yeah
that's it i did it right there yeah but
i got i got hooked right away once i all
started to make sense and then once you
got on board the acceleration goes it
did ever since i've been listening to
the podcast because i'm out in yards all
by myself so i need something to listen
to to pass the time oh cool
yeah so it was really
um i mean thankful for well not really
thankful for covid but then again it
really helped us get through yeah um you
know me as a nurse i did do some extra
jobs for a couple months but i got
pretty burnt out during that time yeah
um he took a job for a little bit and um
but we were able to get through it
and then you just plowed through this in
two and a half years yes we did what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is um make a plan and stick to
it
yes patience and contentment
um
i read the book
from rachel cruz and it was really
eye-opening
now that's a big one yeah love your life
not theirs yes
talking about contentment book yeah good
and then during that time um we both
changed jobs yeah um we were both
unhappy and
and where we were and so we decided you
know we started listening to ken coleman
actually and we got his book the
proximity principle i actually called
into ken coleman show oh wow yes and i
spoke with him you guys are all in oh
yes we are
yes
they're wearing the shirts dave we are
yeah they're in yeah and so now we both
do what we love because i was more in a
finance uh side prior and then i decided
to go back to what i love most and and
that's caring for patients
i got sick of sitting at a desk uh i had
to get out and stretch my legs so the
best way to do it so go running through
some lawns what was the biggest
challenge you faced as a couple
not eating out yeah
i think it was very hard
yeah
um otherwise i mean we've never really
had any arguments about much once we got
on the same page together
um
i mean you can't do it without the other
ones so parts of your marriage have
gotten better
that you feel comfortable telling a
couple million
um
all of it yeah i mean we're
we were already i mean very happy you
know anyways but i mean it's just been
more it's more strong yeah i feel
stronger yeah that's awesome i feel like
we need to do anything yeah
communication is key too i mean
um
and we have goals even if we go out to
the gas station hey i want to get like a
coffee or something is that okay it's
like four bucks all right that's no
problem i mean
can we still still check in with each
other about them yeah we're just talking
communicating create a new language
that's awesome good for you guys yeah
way to go y'all i'm so proud of you
well done how's it feel to be free
oh it's amazing i haven't gotten over it
yet yeah
like just coming down here i mean we
saved up money to come down here and we
don't have a worry in the you know we're
in the world like we were able to just
have fun we went to nashville yesterday
yeah downtown nashville last night and
just had fun yeah it's been great
redneck mardi gras down there
it's unbelievable you know wow
cool guys very cool very cool so proud
of y'all thank you excellent excellent
job man absolutely incredible hey we got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you that's the next chapter in your
story i want to hear from you when you
break that millionaire complain you're
on your way uh also a one-year
membership to financial peace university
and uh if you haven't been through that
yet the brand new videos are out they
have dr john delony george campbell
rachel cruz and me teaching you through
all nine lessons it's the best nine
we've ever done in financial peace so
you'll enjoy it and also the uh uh total
money makeover book and probably give
that away to somebody yeah that you uh
that you know that's struggling or
trying to do the stuff been inspired by
you guys you're inspiring you're heroes
i'm so proud of you very very well who
were your biggest cheerleaders
uh we had some family and friends uh
most of all i think is kind of each
other yes we also had some naysayers too
that were like oh you're never gonna
retire at
and i'm like you know just watch
that's kind of the biggest thing for me
so uh when anyone comes at you with
finger guns like that you know they're
probably wrong
yeah i would also say the podcast i mean
hours upon hours and we were listening
to that i've read dr dr deloney's books
um i've yeah we've read ken coleman's i
mean
rachel cruz's i mean everything we have
just been so
um
just
we've yeah you're just all lit you're
all in you're all in you got to live
like no one else shirts there's no
question it's good for you guys i'm so
proud of you we're honored to meet you
you're an amazing couple very very well
done kirby and amber omaha nebraska
live like no one else 124 000 paid off
in 31 months a complete change of
direction count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
yeah
baby this is how it's done right here
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john baloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today beth is with us she is in
orlando florida hi beth how are you
i'm doing great thank you for taking my
call certainly how can we help
well i made a career change this year
and i left
working for the government where i was
contributing to my tsp and now i'm
contributing to my company's 401k
i've been working with a financial
planner over the last couple months and
her recommendation was i roll my tsp
into my 401k
and i'm a little bit nervous about
making that decision since it's a
permanent decision and i wanted to get
your advice and your thoughts on it
i
always tell people with i mean always
take your retirement with you when you
leave
i'm not sure why she's saying to put it
into your 401k i would not do that
um instead i would just roll it into an
individual ira in good growth stock
mutual funds you've got a lot more
control and a lot more selection there
and your financial planner should be
able to facilitate that are they brokers
do they
do mutual fund investing
yes okay
i'm a little shocked her recommendation
was to roll it into my forehead no i
heard that i don't i wouldn't do that
for the ease of
keeping it all together
yeah
but the thing is you're going to end up
with multiple accounts in your life
anyway
um yeah
and your 401k i mean
it may have options that are excellent i
don't know
i i just don't want i
i wouldn't do that i would roll it to an
ira with her and pick some good mutual
funds and we always tell people to
spread their uh retirement across four
types growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international
that's what i have done
and personally and that's what i
recommend that people do for 30 years
and i always take it with me just
because you've got more options when
it's out there on your own you don't
have to deal with your company's uh
hr department to get to your 401k you
have to deal with the administrator you
just go straight it's just your account
you have your own account
and um
you know you've got more access more
flexibility
more choices
everything and um
that's what i would do with it and if
you're happy with your financial planner
other than her disagreement with me on
this issue um i don't see any reason but
yeah i always take it with me and by the
way that will also outperform the tsp
the c plan
is a strong you know it's basically an
index fund in the tsp the s and the i we
recommend putting ten percent in each
and
eighty percent in the uh c
but that doesn't keep up with mutual
funds
that's going to be less than the rate of
return on a good mutual fund
or a series of good mutual funds so
always take it with you and always take
your 401k with you and do the same thing
when you leave but it's a direct
transfer rollover there are no taxes
if you had a traditional tsp you
relative to additional if you had a roth
you roll into a roth i mean there should
be no taxes and the money is transferred
directly from
your old work to the new ira with your
financial planner that's what i would do
with it
that's what i would do with it
samantha's with us in tampa florida hi
samantha how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh i'm an avid listener but very davish
so go easy on me
um we my husband is active through the
air force he's a pollen air force and
his commitment is up in
two years in this september
we just moved to the tampa area
and we are under contract with the house
with a new construction
i am very concerned because i feel like
we
were out of out of order of the baby
steps we do not have an emergency fund
the house has been delayed from july to
august now end of september the interest
rates have gone up and
i'm afraid
i don't know if we should try to back
out the contract and lose our 15 000
earnest money
or just
go through with it and
just
work extremely hard and hopefully murphy
doesn't move in
well you've invited him in
i know
um
uh i'm a registered nurse but i don't
i'm not we just moved here i'm not
working right now we have four small
kids our oldest is eight
um
yeah
so the the
the psalmist says the blessings of the
lord have no sorrow added to them
when i am doing something that has
sorrow added to it
i have to assume it's not from god
no that's me as a christian
and that's the way i look at stuff
and if i'm buying something that makes
me cry
then that's something i shouldn't be
buying in other words
i mean it's just stressful and
yeah there's i didn't like the base had
an 18-month wait list and
i guess we were just
i don't know afraid you got a house
you're filling up in place you got house
fever that's what should happen you got
you got this
you got to buy a house and um then you
went and bought a house and then you
look down and went oh crap
and um you have now you you
you know you woke up and have a hangover
buyer's remorse we call it how long has
your husband been in
10 years how long have you been married
uh about 10 years you're tired aren't
you
i mean i'm just
like i said i'm i'm just
tired of four little kids
four little kids you're a military wife
and you're tired the way you said two
years september like you you know the
date right you know it yeah you're ready
yeah buying this house um
i don't understand the legalities like
you do dave but buying this house is not
gonna get you the security that you want
it to give you for the last next two
years
it's gonna be a curse it's gonna be a
mess
yeah so um
what i would do is uh
did you do a bunch of customization to
it
no it was just buy as is okay so it's um
have other houses in the neighborhood
sold
yes and it appraised like 50 000 over
than what we signed for it so maybe they
would like
to let you go
and give you your money back
why don't you talk to them
okay so you can make 50 000 more on this
house
and give me my money back or i can close
on it
and resell it and i'll make the 50 000.
but i'm willing to let you have it to
just not close on it if you give me my
money back
okay what do you want to bet they do
that
i got 50 000 reasons they might do that
yeah
that makes sense
yeah yeah but now you're feeling guilty
about doing that
yeah
yes you are
i heard it
i was just as clear
coming from what are you worried about
well because everybody's everybody's
excited about the house but her
the kids are excited but i'm scared no
you should be you should be what's not
what is the house payment going to be
like 3 200 a month and what is your
take-home pay
my husband about
8 800 a month yeah this is too much
house
yeah
and you know it
and you're you're just standing up and
saying
you know there's a little kid part of me
on the cereal aisle that's throwing a
fit and wants fruit loops i love fruit
loops me too oh man bought a house
john this is not about you
and uh
[Laughter]
bought a house and now the grown-up
samantha's having to deal with that
kid's decisions
i make a lot of kid decisions but you're
having to deal with them
the grown-up mom of four
now has to look at this and go oh crap
this doesn't feel right
and samantha you know why it doesn't
feel right because it's not right
yeah a thirty two hundred dollar house
payment on an eight thousand dollar
income is not a blessing
you can feel it in your gut i would you
and your husband go over sit down talk
to the builder in person
and say we can close we will close and
keep our word
but if you would like to refund us our
deposit we'll let you go make the extra
50 000 that this house is appraised for
because we really don't want it it's too
much house and we're scared and talk him
into letting you out of the deal and
giving your money back
i'll bet you they do
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to
slash
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships dr john baloney ramsey
personality host of the dr john deloney
show and number one best-selling author
the book own your past change your
future is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five michelle is in evansville
indiana hi michelle welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave i'm glad i got through to you
today longtime listener um i have a
little complex situation um
my parents filed bankruptcy back
my latter latter teen years so mid 80s
there were um some property that was
given to us or by that dollar
transaction from an ant
totaling about
probably 40 or so acres
with a
separate section cut out to build a home
on after they filed bankruptcy
that was about a house built and five
acres
um long story short my sister my parents
couldn't take out a loan so she was of
18 years old so they took the loan out
of my sister's name and deeded the
ground and the home two separate deeds
in my sister my's name
she's since married and she
her and her husband now are on the deeds
along with myself
my question is this we do not get along
um
my father has passed
my mother had a lifetime estate to this
property for as long as she lived she
could live here however my sister was
her caregiver and there has been some
discord that my sister was basically
maltreating my mother and so my mother
has relinquished her rights to this
property
so
i have never been interested in this
property
it is not my homestead my sister lives
adjoining property that my father and
mother gave her and her husband for a
wedding present
so when i have mentioned
i live in evansville indiana so i am in
different states where's the house
where's the property
illinois southern southern very tip so
crazy is in a pile in illinois and
you're not in the pile of crazy
i am not in a pile of crazy never wanted
pile of crazy have asked to be
purchased have bought out things like
that until this recent transaction when
my mom decided i want out of this i'm
moving up north with my other family
nieces and nephews
and i said to my sister then once she
had mom sign off the deed i went out i
want you guys to buy me out and she said
just sell it
well it's hard to sell a home and for
five acres
half of it to
someone
without her authority
and
okay
you don't have anything in this
i do not
you can indeed it to her and walk away
from crazy
okay
that's probably what i would do okay
life's too short
it is this is a screwed up pal mess
it is these people these people have
done everything they can to duck reality
for decades and twist and turn and the
whole thing's a pretzel and um
now the other option is technically
legally you are partners
and you could file a lawsuit in chancery
court
for the disillusionment of the
partnership which would force the sale
of the real estate
okay
and you would get your half
okay
what would you guess your half is worth
uh
well in that area right now it's going
for roughly six thousand dollars an acre
plus their standing timber that my dad
what do you think the problem is
uh
between that house and the other
anchorage probably around 150 to 200.
your half
my house 75 to 100
no probably closer to two 150 to two
your half is worth to 150 to two okay
correct okay because there's a house and
five acres and there's additional like
20 to 40 acres with timber so just how
much trouble you want to go to to get
that because it's probably going to cost
you 30 grand in legal fees
okay
and you will win
and you will lose
right right no there is no winning when
it comes to family
the only thing the only the only ones
that win these things are the lawyers
but you will you will
i would guess if you have a decent
attorney that you will
uh the the judge will hear you and say
this thing has to be liquidated because
or he'll look at your sister and say buy
her out
one or two and your sister will go okay
i'll do that or
no or whatever but you cannot sell a
one-half undivided interest it has no
value
because nobody else wants to be partners
with these crazy people either
no i don't
no i don't i would give you ten thousand
dollars to not make me a partner
exactly well i would love to turn around
and walk away i was married for 22 years
and actually walked away from about 350
thousand dollars in assets and gave that
to the ex-husband
you know the other thing that could
happen i guess is you could file the
lawsuit or have the attorney let her
know put her on notice that you're
filing the suit you're not suing her
you're asking for the judge to make a
declaration
she hasn't done anything wrong you're
just asking for the judge to just to
declare that this partnership needs to
be dissolved because i'm positive there
are no partnership documents
no no absolutely men of course i was
just probably 15 or 16 when this all
took place 40 plus years ago
as a minor i knew nothing so and they
did this with your sister's permission
or they stole her identity
no actually the sister was of age and
she wanted them to be able to build a
home so she went out and took this loan
out and had me as a co-signer on it as a
15 year old oh well that's not legal
either
no it's not there's a lot of 15 year old
co-signer you can't even buy cigarettes
no i know i know when you're 15 and you
live in this country you can get a
mortgage in illinois
[Laughter]
not really no beer or cigarettes but
i'll give you a house yeah john i mean
is there you see anything from the
family standpoint i don't think there's
anything heals
no nothing
can you afford to walk away
i can i can i know the sad thing is i
know it's not my parents wishes but yes
i can and i am a walk away person so
your parents um
they created a mess
and it's you're not your obligation to
fix the mess to to
create a picture that's going to satisfy
something that they you see what i'm
saying
you're going to be putting together
puzzle pieces on a puzzle and the
picture keeps shifting on you if you
have the energy i might you know
spiritually it's okay to just say i'm
gonna rise above this toss on the keys
okay
there's something freeing about just
doing that and noble about doing that
um from a just a legal strategy
standpoint uh you could just file the
thing
without going to a huge amount of
expense if you want to drop
i don't know five thousand dollar
retainer with a good lawyer and see if
that doesn't bring her to the table
okay because when she discovers what
this is actually going to do it's going
to force the sale of the real estate
that is next door to her
she may come up and go okay if you'll
make me a deal i'll buy you out and i
would sell it to her for 50 of what it's
worth
yeah but that way you get that way you
get 75 grand out of it or something
instead of nothing
yeah
sorry if you want if you want to put a
bluff on the table that's the way to put
but i i honestly would not play it all
the way through
and force the auction
and the drama of the auctioneer if you
win everybody loses yeah i just there's
no winning this deal
i wouldn't go through all that but i
might make her think i'm going to i'm in
for that see if she could come to the
table let's see if we can give her a
little redneck wake-up call
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
august
get this john
august is national make a will month
because august just didn't have much to
do what else we gonna do
yeah it's actually a thing
uh i make fun of if you want i believe
in having a will but a make-a-will month
yeah okay all right well whatever
it gives me an excuse to talk about you
need a will i think it here's what it is
it's the end of the summer and parents
are thinking
i'm gonna kill my children i'm gonna
kill somebody if the kids don't go back
to school i'm gonna kill one of them so
let's make a will that's right that
makes you think about death yes
uh listen you do need to get your will
done estate planning covers all the
documents all the plans all the
conversations
and actually i'm doing the ramsey estate
plan annual meeting next week
the i call it the monty python meeting
where we discuss dave's steps i'm not
dead yet i'm really not dead yet i'm
feeling much better it's just a flesh
wound but yeah it's uh uh yeah that and
so it's a weird meeting where we sit and
talk about my death with me there and so
dave dies this year what are we going to
do with this what are we going to do
with that and
um so forth if you live stream that it
could be our most successful live stream
[Laughter]
rachel's going to have all the pictures
of all the tests
truthfully as exciting as it sounds it's
not
but you do it because it's called
diligence
and you don't have to be an eccentric
millionaire or some crazy guy like me
with a you know or have to have some
kind of offshore account i don't know
the offshore accounts to have an esta
have an estate plan you need an estate
plan everyone needs a will if you're 18
years old go to ramseysolutions.com
estate guide and get our free estate
planning guide
it will allow you to ask all the hard
questions and then you can have all the
nervous laughter and funny jokes like we
do around it but still you got to deal
with the issue don't die
without a will don't die without an
estate plan don't die without life
insurance your family is counting on you
to instruct what your will is what you
what you desire that's your will
what your will is what you desire upon
your death your last
desire your last will
and testament and you testify to your
desires
that's what last will and testament is
and uh it's nothing spooky about it and
no you don't you're not more likely to
die if you get a will you're gonna die
it's just a matter when nobody gets out
of this life jesus and elijah that's it
nobody else gets everybody else
everybody else has to die so
crossfitters will hang in there a little
bit longer than most though yeah they'll
hang in there longer but they're not
going to make it either they're going to
ultimately ultimately that exercise will
kill you that's
but we got cross figures in the lobby so
john's poking at them that's just for
the case you didn't know but anyway
ramsay solutions dot com slash estate
guide it is a free estate planning guide
jump over there and get her get her done
get her done steven's with us in twin
falls idaho hi stephen how are you
hey good dave how are you enjoying doing
better than we deserve what's up
awesome
uh funny thought if crossfit kills you
in the end we might as well just eat
cookies and reese's huh thank you i've
been saying that this is this is john's
theory
and gummy bears exactly i think john is
a gummy bear addict thank you ladies and
gentlemen my name is john and i like
going problem
what's up man
well done well yeah i got a quick
question um about a pay structure that
my boss is proposing to me
it's a little bit different i've never
heard of it and one of your guys's
opinion on if it sounds normal and if
you think it'd be a good deal or not um
he's looking to make me the ceo of the
company so i would get a base salary
which is a livable wage in idaho would
be the base salary plus a bonus off the
profit at the end of the year
the issue i'm having is the bonus
he's proposing to pay out the bonus and
three equal payments over three years
if that makes sense or do i need to kind
of explain that no i understand it um
yeah why the delay if the company is
profitable why can't he pay you
because he wants to keep me long-term
and the other caveat to it is if i ever
leave the company i forfeit any unpaid
bonuses
yeah
okay
yeah um
he i i have uh this is a small business
how many million dollar gross reps
well it's our first year open we haven't
hit a million yet we're at about 500 day
right now but what do you think
what kind of business it's um pay it
it's
pet waste removal okay and your uh your
your uh your living wage will be how
much
starting at 65 and what do you think the
uh how many employees are there three
five
you got five yeah okay
and um
you think your profit is going to be a
hundred
this year it is yeah and so you get 30
000 a year over three years
yeah
essentially yeah
okay um
we coach small businesses under the
entree leadership umbrella
we'll have 700 of them here in nashville
next month and i'll be teaching them for
three days on running the business and
on hiring and firing and comp structures
and a lot of things and i'll be teaching
them base and a lot of our other leaders
will be involved in the teaching based
on what we've learned
over the 30 years of running this
business it started as a card table in
my living room and
now has 1200 team members we'll do about
300 million top line so we've made a lot
of mistakes over the years
what i hear your boss trying to do is
give you great value he wants to honor
you
and give you value
i've been in that situation where i have
a good team member and i want them to
know i love them i want them to stay
but he's trying to create a thing where
money is the only thing that keeps you
around
and if i were coaching him i would say
he doesn't want that you don't want
someone that is just staying
because of money
it's called golden handcuffs
and when someone stays just for the
money that means their spirit left the
building and their body's still there
collecting a check
he doesn't want that
what he's trying to do is a good thing
and i've tried to do wacky comp things
as well
but they don't work
when it's time for someone to leave it's
time for them to leave and you cry if
you love them and it breaks your heart
and um
if you uh uh it's happened to me
i've shed tears this month over folks
leaving our company they've been with us
a decade or for 20 years or for whatever
but
i'm really glad i'm not
holding them artificially against their
will just so they get a check
you see how that's not good for him
follow me yeah i mean i i can see it
because what i would propose to him is
instead what i would propose to him is
instead that once a quarter he gives you
a percentage of the profits
as a bonus once a quarter
we figure out what we made this quarter
we add it up and he gives you that's
what i would tell him i would tell him
to build his comp structure it's a much
more
open hand
and you might leave someday
but you won't leave your body there and
take your spirit and go somewhere else
you'll take your body and leave
and you won't be collecting checks from
him anymore and he'll have that open
payroll to do something else with at
that point
this is a small startup business he's
scratching and clawing
and you know if i were in your shoes i
would just say i'm willing for the first
two years or three years to take less
percentage of profit
and you know we'll escalate it up to a
greater percentage later
like year one i make this percentage
year two i make this percentage of three
i make this percentage and we pay it out
quarterly but i want less money but i
don't want you to think that you're
going to hold me here with money because
no money won't keep me here
good people and opportunity work that
matters
a quality organization
a leader with integrity
these are the things that will keep me
here
until god tells me to go somewhere else
and then i'll go somewhere else
and
that might happen someday
so i i don't try to artificially hold
people with money doesn't work
if you do hold them against their will
with money you'll wish you didn't
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality number
one best-selling author host of the dr
john dolone show is my co-host today as
we answer your questions about your life
and your money in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage in
person
eric and reba are with us hey guys how
are you hey great great welcome where
are you all from uh syracuse new york
area oh cool welcome to nashville thank
you thank you how much debt did you pay
off we paid off 186 thousand dollars in
43 months oh yeah way to go and your
range of income during that time oh
started around 75 and finished around
180. cool nice jump
so uh what do you guys do for a living
um
i'm a risk control consultant for an
insurance company
i'm a mechanical design engineer for an
automation company okay so how did your
income almost triple
um well when we started the plan it was
uh right after i had a contract that uh
with a previous employer that had ended
so it was just her income oh and shortly
after that i got my next full-time job
after the contract work and we were on
from there go to work eric exactly
get a job exactly
welcome good guys what kind of debt was
186 000 a little bit of everything um
the biggest was student loans um we had
medical bills um um
car loan uh credit card um so pretty
normal
very cool how long y'all been married
five years yes okay so it wasn't long
after marriage 43 months ago
uh someone walked in and said
something's got to change what happened
yeah um
so we uh we're down in north carolina
and then we decided to move back to new
york to be closer to uh closer to family
um and probably six months after that is
when
the my contract had ended and a month
before that we had put an offer in and
basically bought a house and my contract
ended you know between
you know
signing the papers and closing and
moving to that so uh and we were blowing
through our equity yes yeah yeah we made
decent money on on our house in in the
charlotte area when we moved and um
looked at that point and that that
wasn't really there anymore and we
didn't really know where it went
so we had to uh
had to change some stuff and uh get
connected to the ramsey way
so i'm rs control consultant like i said
so i drive a lot for work and
music sometimes gets boring so i hit
scan and um i honestly think i was
looking for like rush or something like
that just talk radio
and came across you one day
i don't know what stuck but well we're
no rush but there you go i don't know
what stuck but um
i was at a point because the bulk of my
student loans or the bulk of the student
loans was mine
and
we weren't together financially outside
of paying bills and paying for
a rent at the time so i was stuck with
my huge student loan on top of sharing
the other financial side of things so i
think i was just like hey i can't do
this
by myself so
i don't know we had a conversation a few
hard conversations yeah yeah definitely
yeah um and
that kind of kick-started things um i
had had surgery so we got a big bill for
that and
a lot of scary things kind of yeah it
was uh the house deal messed up the
contract ends and no no we we were okay
with that and um that's now our our only
debt um so we're uh we're gonna be
working on that here pretty soon i'm
excited to get get into that stuff but
uh yeah it was a a long 43 months with a
lot of a lot of different stuff
happening we um
had um
found out we were pregnant shortly after
the you know i got my job and found out
we were pregnant shortly after that um
and then a few weeks after that
um we got a uh a fatal fetal diagnosis
with that and um
had a lot of
i guess not really a lot of decisions to
make and
we're really
looking for control of the situation and
and we didn't have that control and uh i
think that was another driving factor to
get to get into the plan is to be able
to have
control of our finances if we couldn't
control some of the other stuff that was
happening in our life so had that and we
had another baby uh two years after that
um
and uh right between those two we had we
totaled our car um that we had paid off
like three months before that
um
so uh so this has really not been a fun
journey it's been a journey for sure uh
yeah uh
up and down
yeah yeah exactly it's just happening
yeah so um yeah so how do you guys stay
together doing all that because every
one of those things you just mentioned i
sit with people
whose relationship has ended they've
gone sideways and things and y'all chose
to stay on a path together towards a a
new picture somewhere yep and i and i
kind of saw the little exchange there i
mean maybe if you're listening on the
radio you didn't see it but there was a
moment where you almost killed each
other
there's a couple though yeah yeah it was
hard for sure i mean i've told people if
we hadn't followed this plan i don't
think i mean
maybe we'd still be together today but
not in the condition that we're in
certainly um because it gave us a common
goal it gave us something to work
towards
gave us something to think about other
than
the situation and
and
we had carried that baby you know all
the way
as long as we could
um
and
um so with that became the medical bills
and everything on top of it but we
weren't
we weren't stressed about it because we
had better control of everything yeah
not not about the finances at least so
yeah it was um
yeah i think part of it was when we
started the plan and like she said a lot
of the student loan debt was was hers um
and i was you know i refusing to to
believe it was ours um and that was a
that was a big step and kind of had to
had to get that out of my system of you
know i didn't sign up for that student
debt but you know i don't want to take a
step back and lifestyle or sacrifice for
that so i just kind of had to get
get over that and yeah and and find some
maturity there and and get into that so
yeah hey our little eric group comes out
exactly he's going to be in all the way
slow and steady slow and steady
so wait what's something you're excited
about like this has been a hellacious
journey let's be honest it's been tough
but the future has got to be bright yeah
yeah you've made it through this tunnel
man full of alligators and snakes and
all kinds of things what are you gonna
do what's something great that's on the
horizon i'm gonna shop
yeah
yeah she was a uh is a emotional spender
too so it's been a
a tug a tug of war for sure on on some
of that stuff and you know it hasn't
always been
easy at all and you know we've fallen
off and um you know done what we've done
what we can to get back on and keep keep
pushing through what are you gonna do
man
um i think i'm gonna start buying buying
car parts again i've uh i've got a 69
chevelle that i haven't bought any parts
for for a while it's just put gas in it
which is uh another story right now but
um get that thing going and uh and maybe
yeah and find something so just so you
when you go back and watch this again
which you will you're that guy when you
go back and watch this
your whole cadence picked up you smiled
a little bit more you started bouncing
on your feet get some car parts
i can feel it coming out of here
set it to the side and and we're gonna
gonna get back into it for sure i love
it man i think he's an emotional spender
i know he is
he might have me
but it's for an investment dave it's
different it's good it's it's it's it's
a it's a 60s what'd you say 69 yep 69.
god that's a wonderful car man oh man
congratulations thank you proud of you
you have come through so much and it has
reformed you yeah transformed you for
sure and you have transformed to get
through it
as well so uh you're in a completely
different place that you never would
have been in yeah had you not gone
through the hard parts of this journey
and gone through the journey overall
yeah it's uh it's impressive just
sitting here talking to you we can see
the body language shift we can see you
guys
you can feel it off of you how how
much hustle grind and how much struggle
it's been yeah and there's been a lot of
grief that went with it and everything
else and it's good to have all that in
the rear view mirror yeah absolutely as
far as it can be anyway and uh at least
the money piece yeah and you got rid of
that stupid student loan yes
absolutely kept the girl got rid of the
student loan man
so that's the good that's the good
choice
i love growing up eric yeah
well done y'all hey let's bring the
kiddos in what are their names and ages
and we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story this is della
she's gonna be uh sick soon but she's
five right now this is maverick and he
just turned one a few days ago go
maverick all right
and we got a one year uh membership to
financial peace university count it down
guys all right 186 000 paid off in 43
months let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
oh man
cute kids
wow that's fun
man
journeys are tough
but they're worth it
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day james 1 12
blessed is the one who perseveres under
trial because having stood the test that
person will receive the crown of life
that the lord has promised to those who
love him
victor frankl said but there was no need
to be ashamed of tears for tears bore
witness that a man had the greatest of
courage the courage
to suffer
open phones this hour dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host brendan
is in madrid spain no less hi brendan
how are you
i'm doing well it's an honor to talk
with you and uh john you too sir how can
we help
so uh life's moving a million miles a
minute for me recently i just got
married a few months ago we bought a
house uh and then as you pointed out
we're currently on what i would call an
extended honeymoon and that's given us
you know a chance to kind of slow down
we're going through financial peace
together we're flying through the baby
steps like i said we just purchased that
house and it meets all the rules of the
baby steps
but our goal right now is to pay that
off in five years so at a five year
amortization that would be about 7 500 a
month
but my income is really inconsistent
because i'm self-employed so my question
to you is
how can we enjoy the hard work that
we're you know putting into our work
right now but still be you know be
intentional um you know stuff like this
lofty long-term financial goals for
ourselves
what does enjoy mean
um well honestly right now with the new
house you know there's a lot that comes
with that i guess the couch comes to
mind uh
again we're both pretty young so we kind
of have nothing um lawnmower we'll need
a second car you know that kind of stuff
and we're trying to figure out how much
can we spend on these yes we could go
spend x y and z but um we're really
focused on this five year goal and we
don't know okay should we put more money
towards that
above our existing lofty goal or should
be is it okay to go get a nicer car i
know you say it's changed from uh
gazelle intensity to intentional so
we're having trouble walking that line
not buying a cow's couch
and sitting on the floor
would be gazelle intense
that is not intentional
yes not buying a second car
that is a reasonable used car that you
pay cash for
would be intense not intentional
you need to be intentional and do those
things within reason that is baby steps
four five and six baby steps one two
three which you talked about are
different that's intense you don't go on
vacation in madrid spain there but you
do go on vacation in madrid spain for an
extended honeymoon when you're on four
five and six
as a part of your overall
deal what is your income going to be
next year this car this year
uh this year since i'm focusing on full
time it'll probably be just over three
hundred thousand what do you think it'll
be the following year
well last year it was two hundred so i
guess if this growth it would you know
be a little over 400 hopefully
okay what do you do what kind of a
business
uh it was actually just a side hustle i
started in college a few years ago but
basically i review bank accounts
budgeting apps and just help people find
you know the best financial tools
okay all right good for you
that's wonderful okay i hope you make
400.
so what i would do is um
[Music]
set your household budget not counting
couches and cars and extra payments on
the
mortgage just your household budget to
pay the minimum payment
and live
what does that take
and i'll just just make up a number for
right now okay
and have a reasonable life and go out to
eat occasionally and
you know have a reasonable vacation
every so often and so let's just make up
a number let's call that a hundred
okay
and so every month you know you've got
the bills paid for a hundred
and you pretty much are going to make
that
money every single month even if you
have a down month agreed
agree okay
and then what i would do is say beyond
that i'm just going to make a list of
where the money's going to go
in order a priority so everything above
100 i make this month is going to go to
the list
and the list is a list of prioritized
spending
on and saving on other things
okay
so um
you know part of the list is you need to
be putting your 15 aside for retirement
and that part of your list is increased
giving as your income increases
part and those need to be near the top
if not the top two above your living
okay
then you would put the couch
on the list and you would put the car
on the list
and
then you would say everything above that
i'm going to throw at the mortgage and
so if you had a 35 000 a month
you set us out eighty three hundred
dollars for your hundred thousand dollar
budget
and you walk down the list
with the rest of that
thirty five thousand minus eighty three
hundred you follow me
okay yeah that makes sense and so that
month you might put fifteen thousand on
the mortgage
another month you might make twelve
thousand
and you don't get too extra on the
mortgage
because the stuff at the top of the list
eats it up the
surplus above 100 before then
just run you a little formula like that
with a prioritized
plan and go down the prioritized list on
everything over
everything over basic living expenses
and call that a hundred it may be a
hundred it might be 80 when you look at
it it might be 110. i don't care but
it's not 200
and it's not 40. yeah
all right and here's the here's the
second thing i want you to talk about
your marriage okay when you say the word
enjoy
i want that's a feeling
and one of the things that run into
newlyweds is they expect this thing to
feel a certain way now that they're
married
okay
i expected to feel just madly wildly in
love all the time
sometimes you just gotta like sometimes
your stomach hurts man and you got gas
sometimes you just got to mow the yard
sometimes someone's got to do the dishes
right
so i don't want you to default to this
word enjoyment because that's going to
be a target that moves on you i want you
and your wife to sit down together
probably once a month for the first
let's do it for the first year right
where are we what needs do we have for
this month let's check in with one
another and truly listen to one another
and what we're doing is we're practicing
a new communication style as we move
forward
most young couples imagine their life
moving forward and their spouse is just
going to move into their life
and she's imagining the same thing too
and then the energy expenditure is you
dragging each other back and forth
between i thought she was going to sit
down and watch football with me i
thought she was i thought he was gonna
always want to help
make dinner and and
and whatever with me whatever the things
are right
so once a month check in with one
another and let's balance as we go pay 7
500 a month on the mortgage and this
chick wants a couch ridiculous hey you
married terrible she should have been
able to i think we can
i think we can both agree on that i'm
kidding with you but you're flying a
couch for coffee but the but the the
point is that kind of that check-in goes
with building this list right
because as you lay those things out you
are defining
what you want your money to do together
yes and now we're not trying to make the
money do something it's not designed to
do it's not going to give you joy
the
joy will be there
and uh it will give you traction towards
some of your goals and there's a sense
of fulfillment in that
but that's different than joy right
i feel like when paying your house off
the joy is the joy of buying a used car
is about 10 minutes long
right
yes
but the the joy of not having any
payments right being free yeah that's
underneath the money part yeah and he's
driving at that to get the mortgage paid
off and we're both agreed on that we're
both heading that way so it's a fun
thing it's a great exercise so sharon
and i after 40 years one of the reasons
we have an outstanding marriage
is um
we spend almost as much time planning
our time nowadays
as we do our money
and we don't make any big decisions
without the other one involved in either
yeah she doesn't come in and go i'm
going to be gone a week right yeah and i
don't do that to her either right so um
so our calendar um and we sit down and
do calendars and she keeps one of those
old calendars from walgreens yep the two
two oh sheila's got her she's still
right at a glance yep month at a glance
it's a 75 year old product they still
make it
all the way
dave mine's on the computer by god
because i'm a high-tech dude i'm just
saying the most romantic thing i offer
my wife is 45 minutes of calendar time
each week there you go no more
exercising for me you're a regular romeo
i'm romeo that's right i'm just saying
that puts us out with the ramsey show in
the books thanks john and james and
andrew and zach and will and austin in
the booth i am dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you